[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
open phones this hour the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five you can get in if you dial at
this moment that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five dr john
delaney ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the dr john deloney
show is my co-host today open phones
again at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're gonna be talking
about your relationships talk about
mental health about jobs about career
about money we're gonna talk about you
right in front of you
so john you and i were actually talking
earlier this morning in a meeting and um
discussing things around your new book
coming out
um that with
all the wackiness happening in the world
that
i mean your book and some of the
materials that you're putting out are
all about
dealing with your past um
own your past change your futures the
title the new book but this idea that
that you know things that have happened
to me as an individual or to you guys
out there as an individual the trauma
that you experienced
during covid or the trauma experience
from family or the trauma you
experienced from a job or whatever
trauma wherever it was
that's kind of like one set of
anxiety-inducing things you call them
bricks in the backpack right
and then there's a whole other set of
anxiety-inducing things and both of
these affect money they affect job they
affect marriage
because it affects mental health
basically uh but the anxiety-inducing
trauma type things are um i mean stuff
like russia and ukraine uh stuff like
out of control inflation used cars are
going up
all right which makes me think i'm in a
cartoon or something i mean instead of
real life and this must be a pixar movie
i mean how to use cars go up it's
impossible and uh you know uh supply
chain stuff is just bizarre uh just
trying to get something purchased and
get it shipped to you uh is crazy so
people are experiencing
i guess environmental type things that
are impacting us the new negative news
we'll just call it and then you've got
things that are individual to you in
your life that makes sense absolutely
two different buckets how do you deal
with those different buckets you know i
was
on an interview yesterday and talking
about this exact thing and
what i told the the guy was man
i woke i tell people for a living to get
off your devices that's that's one of my
cornerstone messages get off your
devices and be with the real people
and i found myself yesterday got up at
5am to go exercise and do my morning
routine like i always do and the first
thing i did was pulled out my phone to
see if putin had invaded and instead of
looking at it and seeing
there's tension and closing it and going
about my day i sat there and sat there
went to this new site and this new site
this new site so alice went down the
rabbit hole huh yes and i missed my
workout i missed everything i grabbed
coffee and i was able to high-five my
kids and head out the door
instead of
here's the thing you know what i can
control about what putin's doing zero
nothing there's not a thing i can do
about that but no one else can either by
the way
what i could do was i could have got my
exercise in i could have made my wife's
coffee and brought it to her because i
know that little tiny acts of service
when i'm stressed out helps calm me down
i could have written a note to my kids
and said hey i got an early morning of
media hits i love you guys i miss you i
could have done some things that i know
bring me peace and bring my anxiety
level down instead of fed it and so what
i what i tell everybody to do is look at
the things in your life you can control
and lean in on those and literally use
the off button on some of these things
you can check on russia once or twice a
day and that's it nothing else is going
to change
and if it does there's nothing you can
do about it right or the inflation or
the get your house unless you're on the
joint chiefs of staff you don't need to
be riding it all day long you can't ride
it all day long and here's the thing
because it'll ride you it it will
bury you it will bury you my heart rate
is up as though america's getting
shelled right now and we're not right
we're not and so man take care of the
people in your area take care of you and
i'm not saying stick your head in the
sand and avoid it no this is a worldwide
issue we all need to be on uh uh in the
know on this but get in the know and
then get back out don't go swimming and
bathing in the cesspool
right get what you need and then get out
of there man and then deal with your
people in your life yeah the the problem
is
inputs matter
and i mean and if you're incredibly if
all you do is fee and that includes who
you hang around with it includes what
you read it includes your screen
it includes if you're doing social media
or you're not doing social media
includes podcasts you get off work and
you listen to you listen to a murder
podcast on the way home just you can get
to law order svu right yeah for dinner
like you're just feeding yourself this
stuff yeah inputs matter because if you
put if all your inputs are crap your
brain's crap your brain is terrified all
day it's fight or flight all day all day
and then a real thing shows up like
inflation like you go to the grocery
store and you look at your budget and
say
oh i got to make some choices on meat or
vegetables this month that's a real
thing that you need you need space and
capacity in your mind and body to be
able to handle those issues that is
taken up by other fake
drama right it's just going to go and go
and go and go
so you do really need to identify
causes of stress and put them in one of
two buckets things i can do something
about things i can't that's right things
i can't you need to limit the inputs
absolutely all day every day just just
just stop i had a friend's watching cnn
watching fox all day long i think we're
i think he's in a rubber room now yeah i
mean if that's your only input is a
24-hour news cycle all day long
100 of it is hyped yep exaggerated and
bad yes that's exactly i mean it's just
like you know eat i i'm gonna eat
chocolate bars all day long 24 7
and then think that's going to work out
from a nutrition standpoint i mean you
know or whatever negative thing you can
come up with to eat but i mean that
would gag you if you got past four of
them you know but uh it just
your mind is gagging that's right and
it's important to know
you we all should be a little bit
heightened right now we should all be
anxious right now this is a big deal
right and i'm i'm i'm anxious to see
what my government's gonna do to
participate or not participate and what
my leadership is going to look like all
that's true and real and good prices are
real the gas i can't even like i have to
double take when you drive by a gas
station right all that stuff's real
and then what can i do about that i
can't fix the gas prices today and so
i'm going gonna see it and i'm gonna go
man that's that's that stinks i'm gonna
have to make some adjustments in my
budget with my wife and then i'm gonna
go about my day because doubling down on
that man it's gonna make me a ball of
rage that's gonna affect my kids my wife
my family my neighborhood and my work
you got to control the controllables and
set the rest of the crap and control the
things that aren't controllable that's
right that's right that's why they're
not called controllable i mean this is
not hard yeah and yet we have gotten
into this between social media 24-hour
news cycle
um
i mean it used to be
you know walter cronkite for 30 minutes
in the evening your local news for 30
minutes in the evening and you had a
newspaper some of you don't know what
that is you could look it up on the
internet but
um and that was you know you were stuck
with that yeah and a lot of that was
hours and hours and hours behind but
then you had to go sit down with real
humans and you got to have dinner you
got the pontification circles well i
think this well i think this you're
engaging with real people and a real
human would say i think that's dumb i
think this and well i think that and you
had real interactions and your body
actually goes
okay we're safe i got a real person
right here i got a real person right
here we're exchanging ideas and now it's
just grenade grenade grenade grenade
digital grenade that's right yeah that's
right which are about as bad as digital
courage yeah wow
scary times man scary times but you have
to control the situation you have to
control your environment it's uh you're
not going to get out of this otherwise
that's right dr john deloney ramsey
personality dave ramsey the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five
two two five
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
john's brand new book is called own your
past change your future it is on
pre-sale right now for only twenty
dollars and john's got two phds 20 years
of counseling experience packed it into
an easy to understand book this book is
going to have a positive impact on
everyone everyone should read this book
i got to tell you i personally
it's changed some of the language i'm
using not only with you guys but inside
my own head as well and that's just from
me reading through the manuscript
because it's got my name on the
publishing and so i want to know what
the flip we were saying before we put it
out there and it turns out you know
it'll help like a 30 year old that's
looking to sharpen their mind this is
not a thing you have to like
this is a book for crazy people it's not
it's a book for all of us have a little
crazy and we all could adjust it a
little bit that's right all of us have
some things we could polish up and just
you know a little more peace a little
less anxiety all of us could adjust the
way we're looking at certain things and
you give a framework for doing that and
that's why i think this book is going to
blow up yeah there's a lot of books out
there that are scholars talking to
scholars and they're fine and they're
good and they're important and there's a
lot of books out there on
what i call way outside the bell curve
for some significant mental illness for
folks who are practitioners there's
almost nothing for folks who are just
trying to live life better
have a better conversation that's right
with yourself that's right have a better
conversation with uh your friend i mean
the people you love right you know in
our world today we were talking about
this before we went on the air um
you know the number of times that two
people can just sit down and
almost enjoy a good argument just
because we can have a good discussion
because we still love each other we did
before we started and after we finished
the argument we still think you're wrong
but i still love you of course and but
everybody you have to hate everybody and
you have to chop off everything
in our divisive world out there it's
like well you think you you you you you
have a mask or you don't have a mask and
so i'm pissed at you for the rest of
your life you know i mean it's like
people are losing their dadgum minds out
well they're gone man and so you know we
need some new tools
to control ourselves and also to
interface with other people and just to
walk it back you know what i mean we've
laughed internally and not laughed but
we've thought really we look at the
number of conversation cards we've sold
like is that where we are and the
reality is yep that's where we are that
we we're starting over kind of like old
school you gotta get a thousand bucks
let's just start there right that's
where we are when it comes to
relationships and our mental health
right now and let's do it and let's just
stop pretending let's stop walking
around the problem let's go right
through the middle of it well and and to
my knowledge none of our leadership team
or publishing team has significant
mental health problems right to my
knowledge and every one of them were
touched
including me and informed and given new
tools by reading this book own your past
change your future you know we've taught
god's and grandma's ways of handling
money for 30 years here at ramsey and
john's doing the same thing now god's
and grandma's ways of doing
relationships doing mental health it is
a complex topic but uh people that are
smart can take a complex topic and make
it simple around here we call it putting
the cookies on a shelf where everyone
can reach them so pre-order your copy
today at ramseysolutions.com it's 20
bucks you're going to get the audio
version of the book the ebook version of
the book and you're going to get one
month of free weekly therapy sessions
from the fine folks at betterhelp who
have come alongside that makes this 20
purchase an unbelievable deal so ramsey
solutions.com and check it out the new
book coming out in april get it
pre-ordered now to get all the goodies
on your past
change your future our question today
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping with the two new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from david in oregon david writes
i've been paying the bills but not doing
a proper budget since my wife and i got
married i thought i could do it and we
coasted up by for about 10 years then
kids came time flew by and we
accumulated 30 thousand dollars in debt
i never made my spouse part of the
process and held her off so she didn't
have to feel the financial burden
she has a quote-unquote feeling that
something isn't right when i won't let
her see our finances and she's right i
recently read one of dave's tweets look
at you using twitter to help people i
didn't know that was possible it said if
you're in a committed relationship
you've got to play with all of your
cards face up how do we start over and
do it right this time
this is a moment this is it one of those
cool mirrors a really great question i
love this question
so
dave in my life
when i've i've had several of these in
my marriage over 20 years
it always starts with me saying
we need to have a discussion
and i need to i need to
invite you into some hard stuff that's
going on in my heart mine my actions
whatever and i start with i'm sorry i've
been living this way and i haven't
brought you along i've left you out i've
excluded you whatever the thing is
and
i want to invite you in to help make
this right and she's very right to feel
betrayed she's very right or her
feelings are going to be her feelings
but it starts with somebody
turning the lights on turn the music off
and saying i was wrong and i'm sorry
let's start here
yeah
and i got to tell you that i mean i've
walked couples through this
and sometimes i played marriage
counselor for five minutes in the middle
of a coaching session on money uh in
this
and if he will just i got 99 percent of
the time if if dude you got the perfect
heart she's got the right heart actually
both of you do for this for this to be
successful and so
i would just say look i have screwed
this up i'm sorry
the reason i screwed it up was it
started off with i was just going to
take care of it i was going to man up so
you didn't have to worry about it
and then it got out of control and i was
ashamed
that i didn't
do it right
and that caused me to even become
more guarded of it and i should have
just brought the whole thing to you and
we should have worked on it together and
i really screwed up but i screwed up
because i was trying to
be the man and carry this for you and
that's not the right way to be a man by
the way
and i was trying and then when it fell
apart and i couldn't do it then i was
ashamed of myself and i didn't want to
didn't want to reveal to you that i had
screwed up because i felt i felt stupid
and so if he just says that which is
what he said right but if he just says
that to her she's going to be really
forgiving oh man and
this usually when i see a couple like
this there's something underneath it
which
there's something about the way they
communicate in this home that she
doesn't like so if this is
my wife
she will not say hey i've got a feeling
she will insert herself into this
process right so there's something about
it could be that they've been married
five years and you've been married 20.
that's well it'd been very tender first
five years sharon would have been this
now sharon would be like what
it's going
very similar here it's different now
yeah after 40 years you know we we kind
of cut through the bull you know so
those one hour conversations are six
six seconds yeah it's like
not i have a feeling it's like ah you're
scheming and scamming what the crap's
going on
but something here is going to have to
change in how they do because this isn't
just going to show up money it's going
to show up with kids it's going to show
clever
let's let's come up with a new way of
doing business of loving each other and
here here's the lesson that you get out
of this and you learn it through the
money lens and it will affect your whole
marriage to your point and the lesson
that you get out of it that's so
beautiful is this that everything you do
is going to be better when you do it
together right
instead of you trying to give her the
gift of her not having to worry right
that is not a real gift and every time
that's a falsehood have a feeling uh hey
something's not right
develop a language that y'all can ask
each other that question yeah it just
does away with it right right away just
goes away it's poof
you deal with it you move on oh and by
the way this also tells us that your
wife has really really good intuition
yep and so the next time she has a
feeling
about the car salesman but you think you
want to buy the truck anyway you need to
get off the lot yep because her feelings
are probably pretty intuitive probably
pretty accurate yeah it might be god
speaking through her i've learned that
the hard way yeah
if sharon says sharon's southern so she
says she it's a seven syllable word i
got a bad feeling and if she gets a bad
feeling and i go against it cost me 10
grand at least
i just quit doing it i just don't go
against those feelings they're expensive
i've been wrong almost every single time
i just i mean we have to get on the same
page and i i don't violate that i mean
i'll question her i'm like was it last
night's pizza i mean why are you having
a feeling but but she's like no no this
guy i just think he's a bad guy i don't
know what it is but i can't put my
finger on it but i got a bad feeling oh
geez we're getting away from that guy
oh he's playing asap gonna find out
later what happened with him
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
welcome back we're glad you're here
america dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money joe is in st louis hey
joe welcome to the ramsay show
hey dr john and dave thanks for taking
my question i'll try to make it brief we
are in baby step five thanks to you
guys's plan good for you um and we did
it uh we kind of did like a 3b to save
for my car i've got an old corolla and
it's still running great would it be
okay to take some of that money and then
max out um our roth iras for the year
and then kind of rebuild that 3d backup
just because the market's down i figure
it's probably a good time to invest oh i
think so you would be putting in over 15
percent
uh
into our rocks if you are if you put
this into retirement you're currently
putting 15
at baby step 4 already into your
retirement are you not
yes we are but right now we're kind of
doing it we just drafted out monthly oh
you're gonna put a lump sum in it right
now
yeah as long as the total for the year
is not more than 15 of your income
that'll be fine yes
yes that's correct okay
but if you're if you're saying should i
invest more into retirement than 15 of
my income while i still have a mortgage
no i would not tell you to do that no
yeah we just have the money for the car
but the corolla just keeps going so we
were just uh
wondering if we could do we've been
there
and it's a crummy time to buy a car yeah
because they're outrageously priced
right now
so
um
you know i mean you can get a car but if
you and sometimes people need a car
right now but if you just you got a car
that's working and you don't have to
move it so uh what happens if the
corolla lays down what are we going to
do
uh well like we still have uh
enough to
buy something that would work and if we
needed to i guess take an extra two or
three grand out of the emergency fund we
could do that yeah then as long as
you're not over 15 you got
you kind of thought through the what ifs
then yeah i'd dive in on it for sure
have it have at it bro ah solomon is
with us solomon is in new york city hi
solomon welcome to the ramsay show
hi there dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so i'll try to keep it short but
basically
i called the show a couple months back
and you told me that because i'm so
young i should just stash away cash
uh for now
in savings
and so now i've been doing that but i'm
keeping keeping obviously a couple
couple hundred
just like
in my checking account
and i've been recently i got approached
by a few people who are collecting for
charity besides the ties
and i can't help but be a little bit
like
the i have a bad feeling when i'm giving
them money or not giving them as much as
they
as i could
you know
so my question is how do i stop that
from happening
that feeling
yeah
um
i have never been able to stop it from
happening
and it doesn't matter how much money i
give and how much money i have allocated
to give there's always
wonderful things that need help
wonderful ideas of helping people
uh there's a whole lot more places to
give that are valid than i'll ever have
money
yeah that's kind of what it feels like
yeah and so when i kind of get that my
wife makes fun of me and she says that's
jesus's job that job's taken you're not
him
you can't solve everything by yourself
all you can do is solve what's put in
front of you with a reasonable ratio of
what you have
and then release it because you're not
going to be the answer to all the
world's problems in other words neither
am i and i have to relearn that because
i feel that's the exact same tension i
felt it this morning because we have a
budget uh
an amount laid out that we do giving on
our family foundation
and uh a thing popped up into my email
this morning from my daughter that's the
director and and i wanted to do more
than we should
because i like the idea of what it was
and my wife said nope that's what we're
doing and i'm like yep that's what we're
doing because we're not jesus it's his
job i feel that i feel that same thing i
think everybody does so yeah here's the
thing you will not become stingy because
people that ask this question never
become stingy
you don't have to worry about being
selfish but what you do have to learn to
manage is the tension of you can't solve
everything be everywhere have enough
money to fix everyone's hurts and if you
give yourself into a hole
go back to college i used to pick up
tabs for people or pick fill their gas
up if they look like they needed it but
i did it on a credit card right i dug
myself a hole thinking i was being a
hero
and it didn't work right that you run
out of air at some point so make sure
you've taken care of yourself you're not
good to anybody if you're not taking
care of yourself if you're not whole so
you know i th there's two things one is
you're not a selfish person because
selfish people don't ask this question
right and when you get more money you
become more of what you already are so
you're gonna be okay yeah number one
number two you're always going to have
attention and you have to release it and
say i'm not god that's his job
i'm he's going to put in front of me
what i can do and i'm going to do what i
can do and not bring harm to my family
while i'm helping other families and
other people and um and that's the
balance of it
uh
so that that's how i that's how i've
done it but i i will tell you that i
feel this exact same tension
yeah so uh josiah is with us in omaha hi
josiah how are you
doing well thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so i have a vanguard retirement fund
that tracks it's just a mutual fight now
you always get confused etfs and mutual
funds but it tracks with the you know
stock markets and what i was reading is
that we're going to enter into a bear
market and um that one article suggested
i invest i do dollar cost averaging um
invest in commodities i was looking at a
uh mutual fund that just temporarily did
you read the article that said you're
supposed to send it all to dave ramsey
or john deloney yeah um because that
article is out there
no it's not it's not out there but
just because you read on the internet
doesn't mean it's right
yeah matter of fact that probably
invalidates it
that's true
so otherwise i wouldn't be here but it
would still be i know i know that in
times of
volatile times you know you're not
supposed to have knee-jerk emotional
reactions
exactly
but
he who he who jumps off a roller coaster
in the middle of the ride is he who gets
hurt
finish the ride my brother exactly
finished the ride my brother
so continue to invest but i you know
what the right question i guess is like
the 10 000 millionaires that we studied
that became millionaires
the number of them that jumped out of
their investments into commodities
because they read an article and that
made them wealthy when things were scary
in the news was precisely zero
none of them did that
none of them did that they kept
investing and they kept investing and
they kept investing when it was scary
when it was wild when it was fun when it
was good when people are smiling when
they're frowning when they're cussing
and when they're singing joyful noises
all the time they just keep on investing
just keep on investing just keep on
investing you can call it dollar cost
averaging if you want to call it that
but that's not the advantage to it the
advantage of it is you don't stop
investing and you don't change horses in
the middle of a flood
while you're in the middle of the stream
you're gonna drown no no no no no no and
quit reading stupid butt articles on the
internet because it'll cause you to do
this stuff
oh man a friend that got cancer or he's
got a cancer scare yeah may have cancer
or may not and um
i said listen do not listen the cancer
might get you but i will 100 guarantee
you i'm going to kill you if you google
and start reading about cancer on the
freaking internet because you are going
to get bad information a bunch of goobs
on there with opinions about
tomato seeds or whatever else they dream
up and i'm going to pound you if you
open your computer and type in the word
cancer there is one
whenever i see articles like this i
always go to what's the incentive and
there's somebody who's got a commodities
trading office that makes money on the
exchange that looks for precisely folks
like you josiah who are trying to pay
attention who love their families who
are a little bit scared and they say hey
come over here come over here and you're
going to jump off and you're going to
give them your money well let's do it
the other thing is this very very seldom
do you actually get conned by a real con
man right but you can get conned by an
enthusiastic ignoramus
and there's a whole lot more of those
than there are con maybe you just
described social media
i did you did one phrase what phrase
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we talk about mental health as we
talk about relationships jobs career
money it's all right here on the ramsey
show by the way we're going to be doing
a relationships and mental health theme
hour soon
which will of course include dr john
delony and uh that's so we're going to
take questions on in that hour about
marriage parenting family friendships
boundaries your own mental health
anxiety depression
all the things that fall into those
categories relationships of all kinds so
if you want to be part of that
you can go to ramseysolutions.com
ask put mental health in the subject
line kelly i'll get back to you to
schedule you for a call and to be part
of that theme or if you have questions
about those things you can talk about
them today too here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five ramsey
solutions dot com slash ask put mental
health in the subject line and we'll do
a relationships and mental health theme
hour together you and me and dr john all
right matthew's in buffalo new york hey
matthew how are you
oh i've seen better days but i can't
complain if i'm being honest how are you
doing today better than i deserve sir
how can i help
better than i deserve to i love hearing
that i'm a little nervous um bear with
me um i just want to say thank you mr
ramsey and dr john you guys have helped
me um
so much
that you guys won't see the back end of
but emotionally spiritually
financially i want to thank you guys for
all that you do i listen to the youtube
channel all the time almost every single
day thank you how can we help today sir
my question so my question here today is
i have made a giant mistake and i've
neglected um a couple bills and they've
gone to collections and so
well background i'm 19 years old i'm
young i'm stupid and i'm glad i'm making
a mistake today so i don't have to make
it with a bigger mistake later and like
i said these have uh bills have gone to
collections and they're about up to 800
um
and i was wondering if i should
call these collections companies and
get these
um sorted out through a credit card or
through my debit card because if they go
through and
um overcharge me and it goes through a
credit card it'll be easier to dispute
it with the credit card company versus
the debit card company i've had issues
with both and it's been fixed with the
credit card much easier than the debit
card and getting my money back so i just
want to
get your advice and thoughts on what i
should do where i should start
and that's it so thanks uh for that okay
thank you what are the bills for what
did you not pay
um so i did not pay um some toll bills
um for like driving over bridges and
that kind of things and like i said
they're up to eight hundred dollars oh
it's all and you solve that one thing
yeah it's all one thing over the course
of uh about a year now and i was young
stupid and neglected them okay all right
thank you for taking responsibility yeah
we've all been there man that's a good
that's a good first start for all of us
to take responsibility for what we do
and cause
um
so no i would not use a credit card
because i as you know for me i know
you're against credit cards i would not
have a credit card so first thing i'll
do is take some scissors and place
across that thing and squeeze hard have
plastic surgery and um
yeah then close that account so okay
that answered that part now the debit
card yeah you're right i would not give
them electronic access to your checking
account which your debit card does do
and so i would not use that to settle a
collection so you were onto something
there what i would do is just find out
the amount
exactly by having a phone call or an
email exchange with the collector
and say all right if i get back on the
phone with you in a few hours
uh what will be the amount
okay and then go buy a prepaid debit
card for exactly that amount to the
penny
and then give and then give them that
and then cut that up because it's a
one-time use item
gotcha so what about a money order with
that you could do that too that's fine
you just or you could do a wire you can
do a wire if you want to as long as
they're not having your debit card or or
they don't have your checking account
number
and matthew i even i have a
it's a digital version of this i have a
service that i use that's free it's
online that i put my debit card number
in and it gives me an unlimited number
of
numbers of debit card numbers that i can
use for vendors online and i get to say
what the max payout is so if it gets
taken you can't go any further does that
work what's that called privacy.com okay
that's what i use you can try that is it
free it's free yeah it's fantastic but i
put my number in that way
do what
privacy.com yeah and i put my debit card
in there and then any of my online
purchases i don't want online companies
having my access to my checking account
and so i can say you can al that any
purchase can only be this much amount
but again there's probably a dozen of
those kind of companies out there and
obviously do your due diligence but um
like dave said yeah
don't ever give them access to your
account yeah that's the big thing and
you know get in writing it'd be great if
they just send you an email back and say
if you pay by
the 15th of
of march then it'll be this amount and
then you've got that in writing and you
keep keep that in a file in hard copy
and you keep a hard copy of
whatever methodology you used to pay in
the file so this if this ever comes up
again you've got proof that it was all
settled out
and uh the great news is you're now on
top of your money and you're gonna
handle things pay your tolls matthew
well done there you go
all right christy's in charlotte north
carolina hi christy how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i have a well two kids one's already in
college and my son is a high school
junior he's 16 and started working and
he saved about five thousand dollars so
far
his goal is to be debt-free
his college he doesn't wanna he wants to
have a debt-free degree
right now he has three thousand dollars
in savings 800 in checking and he had
bought some stocks he invested
700 and um
then it went up to about 1500 it's down
about 1200 now and i called one of your
coaches earlier and asked he wanted to
know if he should invest part of that
savings for three thousand dollar
savings into a mutual fund and they said
no because he'll need the money and
follow he wants to go to community
college first and then to a state school
so he'll need the money in fall of 2025
and um they said no don't invest into a
mutual fund i forgot to ask him about
the stocks whether he should keep well
they're more volatile than mutual funds
you know right
but he already had those he said not to
invest more of the savings into mutual
funds but we didn't
know what should he sell those
i would catch him
i'd cash it out and put it in the
savings
okay
trap your wins
and uh avoid the losses uh here and
there's two reasons for that
okay one is is that um
you know we're protecting the money that
he has made and it's not gonna go down
further with geopolitical events in the
air we don't know exactly what the stock
market will do in the next six months
it's not a time to be screwing around
with single stocks the second thing
that's more important than that
because this 700 or 1200 or whatever it
ends up being is not going to cause him
to be able to go to school or keep him
from going to school
it doesn't answer right it doesn't solve
the problem so if we lit it on fire it
doesn't end the him going to school
theory right
so
so what we really do with it doesn't
matter that much
but what does matter is what he believes
causes him to win
and if he starts to see himself as a
wonderful stock market day trader he's
setting himself up for losses for the
next three decades
before he figures out that's a dumb butt
idea
and so i don't want to
strengthen a muscle that i don't want
people using
yeah that was kind of his fun money that
was that was not his work money yeah i
know but it's kind of like it's kind of
like let's say he dropped by the casino
and dropped a quarter in and it came out
300 bucks
and but and then he did that again and
it worked again uh then he starts to
think that's where wealth comes from
yeah see we we let him buy those stocks
with the thought that it would probably
go down and he would learn his lesson
and then
brutal hey listen when i was his age i
would have taken that money and bought
laffy taffy so y'all are way ahead of
the game matter of fact you might do
that now i probably wouldn't take most
of my ramsey paycheck
um to the cafe and the dentist but but
yeah shift that man he's on the right
track just shift where he's aiming those
that financial that financial weaponry
and um something that's more sustainable
yeah
when you're teaching kids about money
and letting them participate in
different types of financial instruments
understand that you are
that the actual dollars that are moving
around don't matter much but what the
the lesson that you're teaching them is
this is the way to do it
and that's you know it's like well he'll
learn to be responsible if he has a
credit card no he won't he'll learn to
use credit cards that's right you know
that's that's don't give a teenager a
credit card dumber rock because you're
gonna have an adult with a credit card
later this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your questions
about your relationships your mental
health your job your career your money
your life
we talk about it all right here on the
ramsay show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
john it is really popular right now to
hate rich people because they're evil
and they're greedy and we should hate
all of them agreed anyone who is
successful should be
completely torn down they should not be
allowed to be successful because we want
everyone to be at the same level because
we are now a bunch of communists and so
greedy rich people horrible evil rich
people are everywhere and we have
decided that because the horrible evil
greedy rich people are everywhere that
james our producer decided we're going
to start exposing
how horrible and greedy and evil they
are
pretty regular basis
so carissa collins is the owner of the
popular instagram account the collins
kids which consists of her and her nine
children the social media influencer
revealed on tuesday
that this guy with a 400 million dollar
net worth he's kind of a short guy
and um james no george campbell no the
guy with the guy with the 400 million
dollar net worth that would not be james
and that would not be george campbell oh
that's my bad yeah his name is shaq she
might have heard of him shaquille o'neal
never heard of him yeah so
he took the collins family out to dinner
babes chicken
the next day took him the mercedes-benz
dealer and bought them a 15 passenger
band
after buying the car they went out to
dinner again at the rainforest cafe
where he dropped another thousand bucks
with the tip on the waitress just the
tip to the waitress alone
and after dinner he uh noticed uh
chris's husband's truck which was uh the
heat and air and the air conditioning
was falling apart
you know it was a dumpy truck and so he
took him down the ford dealership and
bought him a new truck who is shaq did
you know i could get i see like elvis i
get choked up people cars i get choked
up on these things man this is amazing
because like let's not blow pat that a
thousand dollars for that waitress at
the rainforest cafe changed her
entire i mean
that's huge yeah don't drive past a 15
passenger mercedes van okay that's just
a little different than a thousand
dollars too but oh my god oh and i saw
this one where he got up all of this he
dropped less than i don't know what that
van cost but he dropped 150 000
probably
and he made he has a 400 million net
worth so that is like
you know it's a very very small
percentage ratio of his world
he's not broke from doing it
i saw this one the guy was in there and
he was trying to buy a wedding i mean
engagement ring for his wife and jack
just happened to be in the same jewelry
store shopping for something
and the guy was kind of getting nervous
and he was trying to he was paying and
shaq walked over and just handed his car
to the the person at the counter and pat
him on the back and said congratulations
my man could you imagine being able to
just do that for somebody just being in
there to buy something for your wife or
your sister and all of a sudden being
able to
i mean come on man it was such an
amazing thing
bought a house for this young man who
was paralyzed by a stray bullet
yeah these evil rich people need to stop
this that is ridiculous that's just
ridiculous that your your evilness needs
to stop that's right
evilness that's a word right
evil in action
shaq you're just you're destroying the
reputation of the evil rich people
come on man with that with that
outrageous generosity come on man
wow that's pretty cool i did not know he
had this uh
knack for random
generosity like this that's very well
played about a thousand places and he's
so he's so subtle because he fills up
the whole room when he walks in it so
there's no way you can be shaq and be
invisible but can i tell you he does it
i saw him i saw a clip of this with the
guy at the zales and it was the most
quiet it wasn't a big hey look what i'm
doing he gently handed the guy and said
this one's on me and it's in his big
deep voice and he patted on the back and
he said congratulations brother and
walked off and it was not a
it was i've been blessed so i can be a
blessing right it's that sense of i've
been given so much and i'm just going to
bless these families and and of course
he's got these big you know things that
he gives 500 kids to clothes here but
but it's just that kind of generosity
man that i can get choked up thinking
about it because it's so cool
um and thinking how cool it'd be on the
other end of this to be able to just do
that well the thing is with our you know
generous people make your eyes leak yeah
and they just we all love them nobody
hate nobody hates generous people no
but but you know you can't do that
if you're broke
if you're broke
and you're bitching about rich people on
your iphone that you have payments on
you can't do that because you're broke
so hello
just just just a little
heads up there
you know bitching about rich people on
your 800 dollar iphone thanks for
pulling the wool thousand dollar iphone
huge yeah james you just you just you're
just showing people how rich people
really are um
we can continue this level of expose
[Laughter]
it's just emotionally distressing to
you know to just
let people see how people really are out
there
because
generosity is all over the place man
wow hey uh
jacon is it jaqen jacon is with us in
modesto
let's see if i can get it on there there
it is jacob how are you man
what's up good how are you guys doing
today great how can we help
good um so
about two and a half years ago found you
uh me and my wife are about a month away
from being done with baby step two yay
and then um
shortly after that once three is done i
have a
six-year-old a four-year-old
and a seven month old all three girls
you are in it my brother you are in it
yes yes
but i was thinking about 529s in their
future
and from what i understand is you can
use a 529 for any family member
so is it better to
get them three individual
529s or
would a
single 529 that i could just load up
earn more money faster
no i won't matter
three with a thousand dollars in them
each will grow at the same exact rate as
one with three thousand dollars so it
won't matter i would open three so that
you've got an individual accounting for
each kid
and you can tell what's going on sit
down with your smartvestor pro they can
help you get that open
but there's no change in compound
interest is compound interest it works
the same way because it's always dealing
with the total amount of money you have
in other words if you take
three one thousand dollar deposits into
exactly the same mutual fund with three
different account numbers or you put
three thousand dollars in that mutual
fund with one account number it will
grow at exactly the same rate
exactly the same rate the fact that it's
separated does not change the math at
all on the total now it does change the
math on the thousand obviously because
it's not three thousand it's one
thousand but
but the uh but on the total it doesn't
change it at all you'll be just fine and
and you it's better to be able to look
at the kids and go hey come over to the
screen this is your 529
and we're starting to talk about your
future and how we feel about education
with you
and where you are going to go to school
and that's a different individual
instead of like okay family let's have a
meeting and talk about the
the group for the community 401ks
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five as we talk about your life
and your money okay married folks
imagine never having another money
argument what would that be like
considering it's the number one thing
people divorce
over money fights money problems the
number one thing they fight about money
fights money problems
when you get on the same page with money
it's like there's not a lot left to
fight about i mean you got to really
work at it after that so
it changes your marriage it changes your
finances it increases the probability of
success in your marriage and in your
money
hello sounds like a good plan how do
people learn how to do that in financial
peace university we've been teaching
people to do that for many decades
almost 10 million people have been
through this class
and many many many of them say it saved
or enhanced
or changed their marriage in a good way
so to join a financial peace university
class you can take a free trial at
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.com
fpu
oh by the way we'll also teach you how
to get out of debt and become wealthy
which is actually what the class is
about but in the process it changes your
marriage ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu phil's in minneapolis hey phil
what's up
hey dave and john uh yeah i'm calling
from minnesota i got a bit of a weird
question that i've never heard answered
before i am a realtor so i work on
commission
my wife and i are in baby step four five
and six she works for the school
district and we front loaded our iras
roth iras in november and we just did
our taxes and
turns out we made over the threshold
so we can no longer put in the six
thousand dollars total so you made over
200 000 household income
yep just barely
but yes we did and so now we've got to
pull money out of the ira and now
they're down about 10 from when we put
them in so obviously that's going to be
money lost they're
trying to figure out how to get them
back into an investment because
everybody from what i'm hearing is
saying that you've got to pull them back
out and put them in a money market
uh you don't have to put them in a money
market that's not required but you have
to pull them out you have to liquidate
these because they're traditional iras
right
no they're rough they're roths
they're roth iras
yeah for my tax pro he says you you
can't do that and then my my investment
dividers is actually an elp
and she said yeah that that sounds right
yeah you have to pull you have to pull
it out but you but what you can do and
your smart investor pro should be able
to help you with this part what you can
do is do what's called a back door roth
and if you you unfollowed
your taxes
i'm sorry
she said that wasn't an option because
what we did is we have so i have a
company that pays basically i have an s
corp and
so i get my salary out of there
so my business taxes are already done
that's already filed our personal is not
done yet
um she said we weren't able to do a
backdoor roth
and i'm not quite sure why she leaned
towards doing a sep
but i can't do a step for 2021 now that
it's 20 22. yeah you got to pull the
money out that's settled what you do
with it is not settled um
i i think there's a bunch of different
conversations going on and maybe they're
getting confused here uh i don't hear
any reason you can't do a backdoor roth
a backdoor roth is a personal move it's
not a business move if you haven't filed
your taxes for 2021 you can still do a
backdoor roth here's how it works unless
they can give you a good reason that you
can't do it and i don't know what that
would be do you have a huge amount of
money in a traditional already
no less than a hundred okay then you you
should be able to do this so
hit your smart investor pro again and
tell them dave said he thinks you can so
really look into it because here's what
i think and i might there may be a
detail of your situation i don't have
yet or i may be missing something in
this conversation this but i don't think
i am
if you can do a back door roth after you
pull this money out which you have to
pull it out here's what you would do
before you file your taxes you would
open an after tax
traditional
not a pre-test okay
and immediately 30 seconds later roll it
into a roth
so i can just roll it from traditional
to roth yeah from an after tax
traditional
not a before tax okay it's an unusual
okay traditional okay but it's an after
tax traditional and you roll it then
into
a roth instantaneously and you could do
it all with the same mutual fund that
you're in
and you know you could do it with the
money that's left that you have to pull
out you don't even have to go all the
way to 6 000 but if you want to add a
little to it you can do that
i know you can still do them i just did
one the other day
well good so i mean i know i know in
general it's possible but i but now is
there a way to roll the current money
that you've got over into that i don't
think so i think you just got to pull it
out
now i'm sitting here with some cash in
my hand from this ira that i over funded
and now i'm gonna do a back door roth
instead and you probably are just gonna
do back door roths as long as they exist
for the rest of your life because you're
probably going to make over 200 from now
on thank god that's wonderful i'm proud
for you
peyton is in portland maine hi peyton
welcome to the ramsey show
hey john how are you guys great man
what's up
so i have a little bit of a relationship
question with my about my parents i'm
20. um i just finished school i work
full-time um i'm on baby step two right
now so i'm paying off my student loans
and my car i just i'm almost done paying
off my car right now um i had an account
statement on my counter and my parents
saw and they seemed they seemed almost
disappointed that i'm paying off the
debt they really they're really
worried about my credit score but you
know i don't know how to
explain to them like the plan i'm doing
that you guys have tried to before but
it just doesn't seem to register and
they were really it seems like they were
really disappointed i just didn't know
how to go about that it kind of took me
back
um i know in my heart i'm doing the
right thing but i want to be able to
honor them
with doing this because they think i'm
being irresponsible so i'm just not sure
how to go about dealing with that
situation with them how old are you now
did you say 20 20 uh 20. all right you
live at home
i do yes okay i'm gonna give you a gift
well this is gonna give you a gift and
it's gonna be a little bit complicated
because you live at home but i want you
to keep this near and dear to your heart
okay
they don't get a vote
out of college you got a job you're
making a living now they do get a vote
because right now you live in their
house and so if they tell you to be home
at nine o'clock and to fold your socks a
certain way you live in their house and
they can do that but when it comes to
how i'm taking care of my money my dad
has opinions
which is fine well and good but me and
my wife make decisions financially for
my household
and you're making your own money you're
making your own job you're paying off
your own debts and they can tell you hey
we think you should do this and really
care about this loan and what
thank you so much for your wisdom i'm
really grateful for that i have a
relative that tells me how i should vote
and they're wrong
[Laughter]
so they don't get a vote okay and what
you what you if man if you can learn
this at 20 that people who love you and
care about you are going to give you bad
advice and they still love you and care
about you and you're going to be able to
move on with your day man if you could
i didn't figure that out until i was
like 35. so if you can figure that at 20
the rest of your life is going to be
good because this is going to continue
to happen that way okay yeah yeah and so
here's the thing um
you know mom and dad i don't want to
disappoint you guys and i know that you
don't understand what i'm doing here
uh and i love you and i respect you
but i actually do have a system and i
actually am working a plan
uh
from some reading and some studying that
i've been doing on how to handle money
and it's working for me
so i know you don't understand but it's
okay i'm gonna be okay
and if i'll be happy to talk to you
about it but i'm but you you need to
separate the part where you need their
you emotionally need their approval
to be an adult that's what john's saying
okay
a great gift man i sometimes when i'm
trying to explain a hard concept you
know if i'm talking to somebody and i'm
i i just don't have the words to explain
it i'll hand them a book and say this
guy or a podcast this guy does it better
than me she this this brilliant doctor
she writes this better than i can
explain it right now and so maybe if you
say hey if you don't fully understand i
get it here's a copy of total money
makeover read this this guy there's a
better job explaining
millionaires that's right just do a
better job of explaining it to me yeah
that's not a bad thing to do either and
go this is what i'm doing and if this
helps you it might be interesting to you
it might not you may just want to stand
back and not agree and that's okay too
you can do whatever you want to do i'm
just i'm going to be going forward with
this thing
and it's a smile and a gentle word no
fights that's right and no there's no uh
acid in the air no passive aggressive in
the
question of the statement
just
be there
this is the ramsey
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper
start your cfo career
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage sherman and christina
are with us welcome guys how are you
thank you for having us we're great
we're great we're excited to be here
we're honored to have you where do you
live in gainesville florida oh very cool
well good to have you thanks for joining
us all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free screen yes all the way to
nashville cool how much did you pay off
203
000 in 27 months way to go
wow and your range of income during that
time started right around a hundred
thousand dollars and up to about 215.
wow sherman did you go back to work
that's a pretty big jump man
i had to get to work that's right
what do you guys do for a living we own
a gym in gainesville florida dynasty
crossfit then we also own a marketing
firm
framework now okay you own a marketing
firm too so what drove this income to
double in two years i mean two and a
half years yeah um the marketing firm
sort of took off the gym was our main
thing for years and then we started the
marketing firm so you know both of them
just sort of continue to rise as we get
more focused on paying off the debt
finally how that works funny how that
works yeah i need some money i wonder
where i can find something yeah that's
good very good way to go you guys what
kind of debt was the 203 um
mostly student loans his student loans
mainly student loans i guess they were
my student loans apparently
apparently that's the worst
[ __ ] i was like i thought they were ours
but they were ours
so mainly student loans uh we paid off a
car we cashflowed a few things but
mainly the bulk of it was student loans
wow undergrad graduate school so yeah
what's your degree in um i got a
undergrad
degree in psychology then i went to a
master's program in biomedical science
but not really utilizing those now so i
don't know jim
probably inform some of the decisions
maybe you realize it or not way to go
guys yes good job very fun so what
started this journey uh 27 months ago
this ramsey idea yeah so we've known
about ramsey for the entire time we've
been married when we first got married
we took um fpu
and that sort of gave us sort of gave us
the foundations to not go into more debt
but
we weren't ready to be serious about it
for a few years a couple years ago so
you're flunked yeah yeah yeah okay
hey i wouldn't say we flunk we we
definitely had we got to see i think we
had to get incomplete tonight i guess
yeah
we just didn't want to accrue more debt
so we were
more aware of you know not you know
working side hustles working multiple
jobs especially even during pregnancies
um we were very much aware like this
this is something we owe and we need to
pay it back we just didn't know how god
would multiply our income in such a way
that from what we were making to what
we're making now um until about two
years ago when we heard a word from the
lord um and we're like you know our
obedience he he has to take care of it
so this is where we're at we're only
making a hundred grand it seems like an
enormous mountain and we're just going
to have to chip away at it and at some
point he's kept away at it and also on
the income took off the income
he's faithful he his provision is
amazing and it's through that that um
all these opportunities started
becoming about and we were able to tip
even further amen and amen
way to go you guys cool
very cool so
all right so you you
you get re-energized yes years later
after fpu 27 months ago you say all
right game on
what was the conversation do you
remember that i mean you said you got a
word from the lord right so there was a
a moment in time that something just
kind of was a wake-up call there's a
milestone there where it turned right
yeah definitely so it's funny because we
were actually up here visiting our good
friends the coaliots up here um in
nashville and i thought i had seen you
all out here yeah yes we've been here
numerous times
people you're hard to forget yeah i mean
ladies tell me that so thank you dave oh
yeah listen i'm not standing by you in
the photos all i'm saying that's all i'm
saying um so we were up here and
up here on vacation and those student
loan people they called me
and that just was that while you're in a
lobby no while we were up here on
vacation oh in nashville and that just
put that i don't know why that just
turned the knife turned the knife and i
was like no more
yeah yeah
yeah
all right so you go and sit down you sit
down with christine and say
so uh for the next couple years we're
not gonna buy anything yeah um we're
gonna have to duct tape the kids to the
floor because they might have to go too
like we're gonna get after this were you
all in yeah yeah she was all lit
i've always been all in yeah she's all
in i would say that's what i'm defender
but i'm also all in tonight
she is the spender
but she was definitely all in she was
like if you want to do it let's do it i
was just like all right i guess i really
have to do it and i started hoping she
would say yeah maybe she was like all
right let's do it because i feel like if
you're caught by got to do something at
that point it's a conviction and it's
just through our obedience that he's
going to um
it's the same trip you're walking around
out here in the lobby yeah yeah that'll
get on you too yeah absolutely and we
did that intentionally i remember saying
well we have to go and it kept us um
it's a drive-through there's the picture
all right i'm not i wasn't losing my
mind all right
i'm in the picture yeah
it kept us motivated it's something that
that um
once god calls us to do something i mean
it's easy for us we don't have there is
no no like
the consequences there is no reward to
disobedience put me in coach don't put
me in this is what we have to do and
then now we get to watch him
um
provide and make a way so it's it was
easier for me because it's like all
right god hands off you work your your
um your miracles and your whatever you
need us to do we're in we're in
well i mean
you doubled your income during this time
so yeah he was obviously showing off he
did he showed up and showed out and i
know i know it's a big way florida's
been been
different in throughout this but you got
to say that 24 months ago running a gym
also in the world your heart's got to
start being a little bit faster right
absolutely you were absolutely you were
exposed right you did but we
that's all we needed so our faith was
strong enough and our children are
amazing like they're
they're gung-ho about anything too and
when we all sat down as a family we came
up with a budget there was no going back
there i mean we were all in and we knew
that god was we knew it would be hard
but i knew that um it would be rewarding
as well so we focused more on serving
others and doing what we could for other
people we also taught a fpu class during
that time just to wow stay focused oh
thank you yeah what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is
i would say you have to have a budget
you have to stick to the budget and
for me one of the biggest things is your
spouse if you're married your spouse
needs to be
on board with you because that made it
even easier for me like christina stays
at home
doesn't work outside of the home she
homeschools our three kids so it could
have been easy for her to say i'm you
know i'm not going to be on board with
this i got to take care of these kids
but she was like if you want to do it
i'm totally on board so having a budget
and then having a spouse that fully
supported me that made it
that much better and i think it for me
it was easier because um not easy but it
was a lot easier to understand this is
not our money we have to pay it back
i'm not mad at the student loan people
we he signed the paperwork i mean we owe
them so it's
you know it is a commitment and back to
it's your
[Music]
it's not that it's something we we
wanted to and in marriage that was one
thing he he always you know brought up
was hey i have this mountain of debt you
know from school and i'm like it's ours
it really is and that's that honestly
was the point i was trying to get to
yeah you're very very healthy we're
poking fun at it but very good very well
said that's very well done we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure
uh that outrageous generosity so you're
on track to be able to do all of that
what are the kiddos names and ages
we have judah here he's eight we have
ariana she's ten we have caden he's 13.
all right beautiful beautiful
good-looking family well done you guys
we're proud of y'all thank you good work
you're amazing people well done 203 000
paid off in 27 months making 100 to 215.
sherman christina cayden ariana and
judah count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream here we go in three
two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
yeah so cool that's how it's done man
that's how it's done
27 months later
game on that is that is a different kind
of game on when you just decide
something
that's when you draw the line the same
i'm with my family you will never call
me again i'm done with you i'm done
don't you're bothering me i'm out the
borrower's slave to the lender and i
don't like it anymore i'm out this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at
talking about your 825-5225 your mental
health
anxiety we're talking about
jobs and careers we're talking about
money
marriage
kids life it shows up right here on the
ramsey show
andrew's with us andrew is in st
petersburg florida hi andrew what's up
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
well um thanks for taking my call i've
been looking forward to doing this for a
while now um i have
a large question but i'm hoping you can
help me out
um
i work right now in insurance i make
pretty good money i'm worried you're
gonna ask me how much i don't know
exactly because i haven't looked at my
last years but i know it's well above
120 it's probably about 150 for the year
okay
i love the company i work for i love the
people i work with it's you know it's
been a blessing um and i've been here
for about four years now
um however i did start a business
renting electric bikes here in saint
pete florida and
it's obviously something i'm a little
bit more passionate about something i
love to do
and
i'm just really nervous right now it's
kind of part time if you will i run it
with my cousin so we kind of balance out
the workload and then my brother is like
our full-time employee so it's sort of
passive income with me working it on the
weekends
and i've got i'm just trying to figure
out kind of how or if i should
transition i never want to give up my
book of business with what i do now in
insurance because i've worked really
hard for it and now it's at a really
good point where i could you know go to
more of a part-time place and start
focusing more on just renewing my book
and not so much on new sales
but it's still scary to like make the
jump you know from going to being sale
sales you know new business every month
and renewing to kind of shifting my
focus
onto
this business um what'd you make on the
business
what's that how much you make on the
business last year
oh well it's it's new it's all right we
haven't given any money
no
no i mean i mean honestly no i don't
need to quit doing anything do you make
money
yeah that's true
um it's definitely not as much as yeah
i'm making now or you're not making any
money
so it's definitely not as much
yeah i i wouldn't have any problem with
you taking a pay cut if it's something
you really want to do and you enjoyed
your life but you right now you're
making zero
yeah so you've got to get this you got
to get the business profitable and i
want to see it i want to see it putting
100 000 in your pocket
right yeah because it's not i mean it
does make maybe a few thousand a month
but definitely not you know in your
pocket
in your pocket
after everybody's paid
after the brothers paid after you split
with your cousin
new bikes they replaced the ones that
the drunks tore up
and all the stuff you have to do in that
business
right right
now once you get it to a hundred here's
the second thing you need to do before
you make the jump but don't even talk to
it don't talk about quitting your other
thing until you get this up to 100.
you're kind of coasting around in this
conversation and i need you to for your
sake i want you to be very very precise
because if you don't you're going to
make a mistake so when you get to 100 i
see two problems with this business
okay that that is that threatens the
future of it
one is competition
as soon as bird put a scooter on the
street three other people did
and if you were all in on bird scooters
you'd be screwed right now
because the competition would have run
you out of business
and electric bikes are another version
of bird scooters okay
the second thing is this is a very
technology-driven
app-driven
social type movement
product
and
if it suddenly goes if it's no longer
it's it's it works right now because
it's cool
it's cool it's it's in vogue it's the
cool thing to do
in five years it's not gonna be the cool
thing to do anymore
so in addition to
having a plan on how you're gonna
survive the competition you need a plan
on how you're going to
uh
add other types of product lines that do
not falter as quickly when they're not
cool anymore
when you have a fad
product
when the fad's over your business is
over if you don't have another product
and so in addition to
electric bicycles
uh
you know i mean if you think about look
back five years five years ago no bird
scooters no electric bicycles
they just showed up boy i mean this is
it
and so uh something else is going to
show up they'll go it's as fast and it's
just it's not going to be cool
that's what i mean by cool it's
something you run a fad product line
something in a high rate of change
industry you got to have a plan for
where you're going next not i'm going to
do this for 20 years with like bicycles
because 20 years from now you won't be
doing electric bicycles i promise you
and this is a strange call uh andrew
because 99 percent of time someone calls
it's i'm a nurse and i cannot do this
anymore i'm a teacher and i cannot i'm a
police officer and i can't
the way you talked about your insurance
company and the p you like it you love
these people and so here's the thing
there is this weird pressure going along
around people who are 25 and younger if
you're working for a company that
somehow you're failing that if you're
not quitting your job to go do your
quote unquote own thing
um that you're somehow less than
i call that's not true bullcrap on that
if you love your job you're making 150
grand and you're good at it you're
building it there is nothing wrong with
staying there and crushing and hustling
it there with with your company man so
the third option
is
uh
stay in the job permanently
do the things i'm talking about with the
business
and get the business so profitable that
you just staff it
and run it and you're an absentee
investor that's what i like you're not
an operator hire some high school kids
to run it for well he's got he's got the
brother in there starting it right first
full-time employee so we can put some
other employees in there as the
profitability goes and let's run that up
but you still are going to have to look
at how you're going to double and triple
the revenues you're still going to have
to look at how you can diversify your
product lines because you're in a very
i don't know i don't know the other
proper word to use other than fad you're
in a very v in vogue product in a high
rate of change industry and you're going
to get your head taken off with that
because you're going to just wake up one
more it's going to be over
and and you're sitting there with a
whole bunch of bikes 75 electric
electronic bikes yeah i mean it's just
that's going to be a problem and it's
not going to be happening tomorrow it's
not going to happen next year but five
years from now
i mean you know you may be using
hollywood you may be using holograms to
book the deal you know i mean i don't
know
so
all right rose is in tampa hi rose how
are you
thank you for taking my call dave and dr
john
sure what's up can you hear me okay yeah
so my question is i have i currently
have two rental properties and one of
them will be sold this summer that'll be
out of question but i have a town home
that i it's empty right now tenants just
moved out um and i'm wondering if i
should sell it or keep it long-term
what's it worth
about 217. is it paid for
i have 45 000 which i'm going to be
paying off
so let's pile up 250 000 let's pretend
you don't own the town home
and i just put 250 000 cash stacked up
in the middle of your dining room table
what type of investment are you going to
do with that are you going to buy rental
property
are you going to invest in mutual funds
what are you going to do with that
everything else i have is in the market
and so for me real estate was this
is just not having 100 of everything in
the market do you want to buy with your
250 000 in the middle of the table
do you want to buy a piece of real
estate
i'm unsure that's why i'm calling okay
there's not a wrong answer
yes is the right answer and no is the
right answer um because it's what you
want to do real estate is not a bad
investment
this is not the perfect time to sell if
you should be holding i'm not selling
mine i got a bunch of it and i'm keeping
it
and i'm just smiling that it's worth a
lot more and that the rents are going up
on all of it i'm just smiling
uh but if uh
if you are sick and tired of real estate
you there's no law that says you have to
own real estate
so you can sell it
but if you would buy more real estate
with that money then you would keep this
if you would sell it if you would not
buy more real estate with it then you
would sell this that's how i help
analyze it help me walk through the
emotions in my situations
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
money your relationships your mental
health your anxiety your job your career
anything having to do with your life
marriage parenting it's all here
it's called the ramsay show the phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five joe is in st louis hi joe
how are you
hey dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up i i called you
i discovered you about seven years ago
on the radio
and i'm 71 years old
my finances are all my life been up and
down
and i can tell you that i paid my
mortgage off yesterday and i'm debt-free
too late it's never too late to learn
and i learn from you
and that's what i called you about i'm a
little nervous now but uh
i took 99 of your advice
i didn't do it all but i took 99
and i want to tell you and other people
out there it's never too late
yeah so you're starting here you start
in your mid 60s and you paid off your
house when you're 71. i'm so proud of
you 71 i paid it off yesterday that's
awesome what's this house worth
oh about 150. look at you with a paid
for house
i've been up and down in finances and
income all my life
and i live pay paycheck to paycheck
until you
and i just wanted to say thank you well
thank you you're an inspiration sir
uh you're i appreciate it honored you
called never too late and never too late
so what's your house worth you think
you said 150 100 you said 150 150 that
was yeah yeah and and
still working
yeah i'm retired but i work part-time
okay and uh
but my finances have never been the way
they are now
just because of you so you not only got
a paid for house that has gives you a
sense of peace
but more than that more importantly you
have a sense that you're under control
oh yes i've never been under control in
all these years with my finances they've
been up and down i had a lot of things i
lost a lot of things
but
but you are now right now you are now
i'm sitting on the banks of the
mississippi river
and i'm looking at bald eagles flying up
and down the river right now
life is good much better than that thank
you for your gratitude my brother that's
awesome that's just beautiful just
beautiful thank you so much
robert is in modesto california hi
robert welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um
actually i want to listen to your
podcast maybe three times in the start
of this week wow i'm surprised i
actually got through to talk to you
welcome to the gang man
welcome in brother
tell me about two months now that i
needed to listen to you um we're kind of
in the wiper i don't know if we're on
the same page here she's 48 i'm 54 i
make 100 000 a year
just over that i was a paramedic um here
in california
and we are 300 000 up on equity in our
house
i have about six hundred thousand in
401k
75 000 in cars and um
about 30 000 in debt that's a student
loan and a credit card
my wife wants to go to a larger home
because we are
small at home four of us here 19 year
old 15 year old me and the wife and
we're just running out of room here she
wants to go to a larger home to me
that's
a larger payment
you know a little less stress on the
on us space space-wise a little more
stress on us financial wise she advises
if i do the ramsay thing
then uh you know
we'll find the money type of stuff is it
a bad idea to go to a larger home
i'm sorry the last part about the ramsey
thing say that again
she says if we start doing the seven
steps and doing the ramsey method that
it um
it'll all work out that the
the the more payment is not going to be
that big a deal because we'll find the
money somewhere else the baby steps
aren't pixie dust brother yeah the
problem is the problem is that the the
ramsey thing is going to cause you to
not go get a home because you have other
debt you've got to clean up before you
talk about doing that
30 000 worth
okay you don't move up and home until
you get that mess cleaned up
the the consumer debt that you've got
right and you're running out of room in
your house you got a 19 year old that
[ __ ] will probably be taken off soon you
got a 15 year old that's just got a
couple of years left i mean this sounds
rather relatively temporary right
yeah you were running out of room 10
years ago yeah now you're not running
out of room now they're running out of
the house
yeah we've been in this house for 20
years that sounds like more of the issue
than the space issue because y'all want
to go do something i don't mind you all
moving to a different home even a more
expensive home i would not do it because
you're running out of room because your
kids are about to leave in an eye blink
i'm with john on that i would not do it
until you get your debts paid off that
you have other than the house
and then that would entail that you are
working the ramsey baby steps that you
have your fully funded emergency fund
your debt free except the house and then
when you make the move on the house your
payment is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed rate
and then we plan to work extra and pay
that house off sooner than 15 years
because that's what people that become
millionaires do
that would be the ramsay plan not um
we're gonna move into a higher house
payment and then we're gonna start seven
baby steps and that'll make it work out
that's right no lady that is not the
ramsey plan
sorry and robert make sure that you
don't have three hundred thousand
dollars of imaginary equity burning a
hole in your pocket yeah a lot of folks
feel like oh my house is worth this so
now i have to go x y and z because when
you sell in an up market you also have
to buy in enough that's right that's
right
so hang up
man
i'm a hang on to it man that that itch
might not be scratched by just
spinning that money that you don't have
yeah so i i
i think we need to redefine why we're
moving you can't be the two kids because
they're not going to be there and say
i've lived here for 20 years i want to
do something else that's great that's
okay that's wonderful that's okay that's
not a bad thing but we're running out of
room that you should have said that 10
years ago that's right because you were
out of room then
um if you're going to use that one it
sounds like you'll y'all feel like you
have a 300 000 blank check and you don't
that's the part i'm worried about
i think she went out to some open houses
and saw some nice cabinets in the
kitchen no
that's never happened at our house
oh jeez
it's like i'm just gonna go to the car
lot and look at them that's right at the
bentley lot i'm just gonna go
drive the
drive the maserati that's all i'm gonna
do
yeah i'm just going to drive the new
raptor
would you look at that screen
i don't know how people make it without
a screen that size
yeah it's uh we all do this is what
we're saying not just your wife but i
think she
uh i i i might accuse sharon ramsey of
doing similar things like she goes to
some friend's house or to an open house
or i'm just going to stop by and look i
want to see what people are doing in
kitchens these days suddenly the ramseys
are like oh
or we're tearing the whole freaking
kitchen out yeah and which usually means
that 24 months after we do that we're
moving then you're moving but yeah so
yeah
this is a this is an ailment that is
common to lots of households robert this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
well real estate market's pretty hyped
up right now if you hadn't noticed the
buyers are feeling the pressure to buy
the sellers are going i can get a lot of
money it's not amateur hour out there
don't get me wrong rates probably won't
get any cheaper than they are right now
uh doesn't give you a reason to green
light stupid okay
you don't necessarily need to get caught
up in the hype the flow the tidal wave
whatever you want to call this
or you don't have to get caught up in
offering way over asking price because
you're desperate don't get caught up in
the hype
you know you got to get your head out of
the craziness and get a second look at
the facts are you debt-free do you have
a down payment
are you putting it on a 15-year where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
only if the answer is a big fat yes are
you ready to buy but if you're ready to
buy
we can help you with this
once you've answered the questions it's
time to look at some old cold hard
numbers
you can use our free mortgage calculator
to see exactly
what your home ownership options are
based on your budget
real ramsey stuff
so go to ramseysolutions.com
click free tools
use the mortgage calculator it'll tell
you what to do
ramsey solutions.com click free
that's a keyword right there free tools
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time a great american company
blinds.com always use ramsey as a promo
code it's magic it'll get you the best
deal all right today's question comes
from megan in wyoming megan writes i've
been married for 14 years and due to
anger issues i need to leave my marriage
and take our children with me
i'm struggling with how to pay bills and
find a place for him to live
i'm in the first year of a great career
but my pay is not yet consistent i earn
50 000 a year and my husband makes about
the same amount
i feel like i need to be financially
responsible for the house we own
together and an apartment for him to
move to when we separate
how should i plan financially to be
ready to leave him
if you have come to a situation in your
marriage where you are not safe
and you decide to terminate your
marriage because somebody has made it
your home and your relationship
inhabitable you are not responsible for
finding them a place to live
that's their responsibility
yeah
this is hard man buddy of mine that does
divorce recovery many many years ago
here on the air said divorce changes a
marriage into a business transaction
this is no longer about you taking care
of him
far
from your need to take care of him
you're having to end this because he
can't control himself
so his rage and anger issues so
um
time for the mad little boy to grow up
and get his own apartment in his own
place that's right yeah
so um yeah you know
that feels um
like an abuse abused language exactly
what it sounds like like i need to take
care i need to make sure he's okay
to keep him calm right while i do this
big big thing yeah just so i go over
here and do all the adult stuff i need
to keep him calm that's right
and uh and or uh
i'm worried about him
even i love him even though i don't you
know and that that's all that's all
abused language right
abuse so megan you need to get yourself
a excellent attorney who will walk
things through with you you need to get
a couple of women in your life that will
walk through this with you
and
you can bounce decisions off of get a
good pastor a counselor that can walk
with you you're going to need some
support here and you trying to make sure
all the teas are crossed and eyes are
dotted including where he's going to
live and how he's going to eat and what
kind of car he's going to drive you're
taking on too much taking on too much
when someone leaves
and we you call them the ex-husband
it's because they're not the husband
anymore that's right yeah that's why we
call them ex your responsibility for how
they choose to live and eat is no more
x's used to be
not anymore right your problem now over
that's what that means so it's a is a
clear line there of your responsibility
like when he walks out the door with the
suitcases that line is following him
correct and it's going to follow him as
he drives down the street like some kind
of a bad progressive commercial or
something right but
yeah and and that's okay that that's
where your line of responsibility ends
is right at his butt as he leaves so
let's take him out of the picture
mom needs to just simply circle back to
the baby steps right now she's got her
and i don't she doesn't see how many
kids let's say she's got two kids and
she makes 50 dollars then she needs to
say can i afford this home on fifty
thousand dollars can i afford the four
walls bills and transportation and food
can i take care of my
necessities right as i make this this
transition and i would even go as far to
say
you need to take care of yourself if
you're not safe whether or not you can
afford that house it might mean that you
got to move to an apartment for a season
and the house gets sold that's right
yeah
so here's the last part of that that you
know that's where i was going to is
i'm going to make the number up but i'm
not far off
as i have worked over 30 years with
these situations where
there's a divorce mom wants the lady
wants to stay in the home
in this case she makes the same amount
of money usually she makes less
statistically right okay not saying
that's right or wrong it is wrong
obviously
if she does less she should make less
but if she does the same she ought to
make the same
so uh anyway she's got the same amount
of money here but the household income
is getting ready to be cut in half
i need to the kids world is rocked
because of the marriage ending
dad's not going to be in the house the
kid's world is rocked the kid's world is
rocked and i need to provide a safe
place
stable environment for my kids i don't
want to give them any more change
than the change that's already occurring
so i don't want their school or their
friends or their bedroom to be upset so
i'm going to keep a house i can't afford
right and i gotta tell you that happens
a lot it does and instead of you getting
a fresh start after this
you're starting in the hole after this
but now it may not be the case and maybe
you can afford the house it's okay but
john's advice there to where you say i'm
gonna really look at the budget and
decide can i afford on my income to keep
this house otherwise the house needs to
be sold as part of the divorce here's
what it is it's i want to prop up this
picture of family life yep and i'm just
gonna i'm just going to cut him out of
it but i'm going to keep this picture
propped up and you need to know when you
file for divorce everything's different
yeah that old picture is oh and those
kids are not better off in a house you
can't afford in your stress in their old
bedroom that's right than they are in a
brand new apartment that you can afford
uh and your stress level is way down and
you can be emotionally present for them
because you're not crying over the bills
after they get a new environment can
help them actually make a psychological
shift that now we're in a new world
that's actually helpful sometimes yeah a
visual of that's not bad that's right
yeah
so it's not it's not always the best
thing to keep the house yeah it's not
sometimes it's okay
most of the time it's not
it's not so you you're not telling you
have to sell it but i'm telling you got
to put it on the table that that's a
possibility and i'm heartbroken for you
megan yeah that's awful [ __ ] should be
thinking about you
awful awful awful awful open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
um
shane on facebook says can you
distinguish the difference between
enabling and helping
yeah uh
helping helps enabling enables i i think
wow did you go to school for that yeah
that was that was an entire class i paid
for 900 an hour um i if i'm helping
somebody i am
walking alongside them as they get
better they improve their life they get
closer towards their goal enabling makes
me feel better not them right so
enabling helps me think i'm doing
something makes me feel like i'm doing
something to support somebody they're
actually not been not only not
benefiting from it their life is getting
worse because of my my participation in
their life
enabling is a drunk gets a drink right
he feels better and you think you helped
but you didn't you harmed
helping is i'm gonna pick you up and go
to aaa with you the first meeting
helping is i'm going to embrace
suck with you and we're going to go
together and get this thing
messed straightened up
and so um but enabling
makes feels like you did something you
called it helping
but it
allowed the person to continue in the
destructive behavior
enablings for me helpings for them maybe
that's the best way to say that enabling
is helping is often labeled as tough
love
enabling is often labeled as love by the
person who's getting the gift that
shouldn't be getting it
that's good all right i feel better now
i do too
i feel totally helped i was i wasn't
enabled i feel enabled but i wasn't
enabled but it didn't happen not right
here on the air this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
in the lobby of ramsey solutions right
here on the debt-free stage is none
other than gary and jill welcome you
guys
thank you we're excited to be here well
we're honored to have you where do you
guys live
um so we're from alexandria virginia
right outside of dc yeah welcome to
nashville we uh we brought the sun out
for you today thank you for that yeah
it's a nice day out there if you're a
duck
in this rain
but uh oh my gosh welcome so uh down
here to do a debt-free scream how much
you paid off
658 thousand three hundred and eleven
dollars oh
how long did this take six years all
right i love this
and your range of income during this
time
142 thousand
and 272 000. cool what do you guys do
for a living i'm so i'm a teacher
and i'm a certified public accountant
and owner of steward solutions ah very
good very good so what do you what do
you teach i teach first grade um with
dcps in right in washington dc yeah good
for you yeah very cool you are you've
had a boring last 24 months yeah i've
been really bored
wow well the kids have never been the
problem it was always the parents and
the administrators that's the only
people we've ever had to worry about
yeah way to go you guys very cool all
right i'm guessing with these numbers
six hundred fifty eight thousand and six
years you paid off your house
i wish
no they're in dc six six hundred
thousand it's a garage apartment right
yeah you can't buy much with 650 in dc i
know i know but i thought oh no what guy
would you do richard what'd you do
i mean we had a wars
a line of credit on our home
um 218 000 was credit cards
uh 162 000 was student loans
and then just a bunch of like
miscellaneous debt
you're a cpa
you're 200
dollars in credit card debt
it was bad explain this to america
we were having a lot of fun
and thank you
oh my god yeah our our lifestyle was out
of control and you know like you said 80
of you know building wealth is behavior
and our behaviors were out of whack with
our
income our income yeah oh
my goodness wow
okay so um how long have you all been
married
um this will be seven years in june yeah
so you did dismiss before marriage
really yes we had two messes and then we
made it one big mess when we got married
it was really nice that's so beautiful
so sweet
it's so romantic yeah
very special
i mean you guys get married and it's
like you must have been thinking
everything's great and then all of a
sudden you're like one you're in and
you're like holy crap so
when when did when did you realize i
don't i don't want i don't want to put i
don't want to put words in your mouth
tell us what happened that's pretty much
what happened so we got married in june
of 2015.
um you know then we like continued our
frivolous lifestyle for about six months
and going on vacations and just like
kind of doing whatever we wanted having
fun being the like
the goal um which we did but then we
started to merge our finances six months
later and gary actually you know came to
me and was like this is really a problem
we have way too much debt and i
was not agreeing with him i was like
this is normal everyone has student
loans everyone has cars everyone has
that was like
that was bad but
um all right gary i'll give you 200 000
credit cards but listen listen right
i'll give him that yeah i was like that
that is bad um but i was like a big mile
person so i'm like well think of how
many miles work
i was bad so
give us our own airplane yeah
wow so gary um brought financial peace
to me i it took me a little while to get
on board but when he you know um
he was really the leader of merging our
finances because i'm like i don't want
to talk about money i don't want to do
it you're the accountant you're the cpa
make this go away gary yeah just like
fix it whatever you do you have the
degree fiction i don't know i teach
first grade i love you you're amazing
you teach first grade so awesome right
you're a cpa right yeah and you had
600 thousand dollars in just consumer
debt exactly this is incredible so i'm
trying to help the little people now i
have a whole lot
about it
but
but yeah so then she laid it all out for
me so you went through financial peace
at a church together um so actually i
read the total money makeover book first
and that really just like blew my mind
and then i was hooked on everything
right from there and then
i found the at-home financial piece oh
okay it was actually like dvds yeah and
back in the day yeah yeah convinced her
too 2015 when people had dvd players
yeah
kind of convinced her to um
you know go through the program with me
and we kind of eased into it it was not
a you know
i wish it was like you know right away
but it took us probably the first
you know 12 to 18 months of the six year
journey to really click and get on the
same page and what was your best fight
oh probably the cutting the credit card
i feel like i really couldn't deal with
that
yeah that was
i mean we had 28 credit cards
28 yeah and it was bad yeah you know
when we started doing the debt snowball
and you are giving america hope yeah
that's why we're here we just we give
everybody we started off if you guys can
do this by god anybody can do it that's
amazing i love you the psychology behind
the last one getting hurt
i've had people i used to cut them up at
this on the stage after an event and
sign books for hours
and i've had people cry
they would just weep when we would cut
up
their probably
about this card since i was in college
like it's an old girlfriend yeah that's
oh my god
yeah it's hilarious oh man you guys are
fun i'm so proud of you because what
you've done is so
big it's so herculean
and so there had to be a moment in time
so you said there it took about a year
18 months to get real serious and get it
dialed in and then we're like cut that
last card now we're game on and then
there had to be another moment where
the uh momentum shifted and you went
like hey we're going to win this
where was that
i mean we so our debt snowball had like
54 items on it yeah um
there's a lot of yeah um
28 credit cards yeah i think once like
after the first two years and we and we
got like a third of the way through the
list
momentum started picking up and we
started doing stuff that
you know like working side jobs and
selling stuff out of the house and
about that time i got my cpa license so
i started doing you know tax returns and
and i joined um
ramsey preferred coaching and started
coaching other people how to win with
money and
it was really cool to you know do
something i was passionate about but use
that side income to speed up our
progress
that's cool well and you got a story
i mean you can tell people that stories
like me telling stories going broke you
know i mean it's like you know hey i
know you i know you think your twenty
six thousand dollars in credit card debt
is bad but let me just tell you let me
just
i couldn't tell you about that
so have you had the moment where your
your teacher check and your business
check is deposited and no payments you
have no payments
yeah yeah we have no problem we have a
mortgage but we don't have any consumer
debt payments that's why
it looks great you guys are amazing
you're so such a powerful thing you've
done
i mean i mean it's such an extreme
transformation
yeah when we first got married and you
know she just threw the the finances at
me and was like here you go and i had a
lot of stress and anxiety because i i
was do i was living and breathing it
every day and um you know put a lot of
weight on me and just to have her agree
to come in with me and work together and
share the burden with me the last six
years uh it really like helped our
marriage and made us closer yeah so
powerful congratulations you all too
very very powerful well we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you you're
going to be there before you know it you
can do this you can do anything man this
is so amazing so amazing and you're a
neat couple and thanks for letting us
cry with you there for a moment because
it just takes your breath away but
what you've done is amazing that's
that's the story is the size of the
mountain you climbed all right 658 000
paid off in six years of that over two
hundred thousand credit card debt making
142 to 272. count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one we're
wow
you are
free
i love it no more excuses america they
just took them away from you ding ding
you thought you couldn't do it they did
it there it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day james 14 4 you
do not even know what will happen
tomorrow
what is your life you are a mist that
appears for a little while and then
vanishes
lillian dixon said life is like a coin
you can spend it any way you wish
but you can only spend it once
how you gonna do it what are you gonna
do
this is the ramsay show dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money leanne is in canada hi leanne
how are you
hi i'm doing well how are you guys great
how can we help
well thank you first of all for taking
my call
my husband's actually an avid daily
listener and follower of your plan and
he got me hooked on it by playing the
podcast on our honeymoon last year and
then gave me the total money makeover as
a like a light beach read he's like a
real romantic it's the least romantic
honeymoon i've ever heard of that's
awful
it actually was
it was a great way to start our marriage
so it worked out nice
very good
it must have been episodes that me and
george were on go ahead
oh there you go
um so we have no debt besides our house
which we owe about 330 000 on
um we made it our personal goal to try
to pay it off within five years was
possible
and then we bought it in 2019 so we have
about three years left if we are to
fulfill our goal
um
we have a fully funded emergency fund
right now but my question is about a
decision that i have to make primarily
by
the 10th of march
right now i'm a 23 year old licensed
practical nurse who
um like i signed up for school online to
get my registered nurse through a
university in alberta i'm finishing
three courses by the end of march and
needs to sign up for the new courses by
the tenth
i have about two years of full-time
school left if i'm to continue
the issue is that i unfortunately got
fired due to the mandates up here in
canada and could potentially lose my
nursing license
um and i'm not really sure what the
future of nursing is going to hold in
the next few years so to speak um so i
don't know
if it's going to be worth it for me to
keep taking the courses if i should work
harder than now
or casually or even if i should be
taking them at all because we're able to
cash full of my courses with my
husband's income and then a little bit
of my own
but i'm not totally sure if we'll be
able to reach our goal paying off the
house that soon if i do school on top of
it
so
i'm not familiar with
the overarching issues in in
uh
are the are the details i should say of
uh
why you were fired but i'm guessing that
you uh chose medical freedom you wanted
to decide what happens with you and and
they said you have to do something
regarding covey that you didn't want to
do
that's correct yeah okay and is that an
industry-wide thing i mean
she you said take your nursing license
because you choose not to be vaccinated
is that what you're saying
so that's a potential that they've sort
of been rumoring around
and i won't know that until probably
like the 24th of march
is when they're expecting to rule out
that mandated government
yeah because they
you know yeah
and our um the totalitarianism of that
is just shocking yeah i i can't imagine
that they would lose the force they
would i mean i've been surprised before
so well they they've lost their entire
trucking industry yeah on the same exact
issue yeah they shut the trucking
industry down
because truckers aren't they're not
working in canada because of this exact
same thing and if all the nurses or a
portion of the nurses don't work now
um and they're willing to do that on on
the issue of a vaccine or on the issue
of the power is really what it is but um
oh my gosh wow well medical freedom is a
big deal uh being able to make your own
choices is a big deal so
you're i think i'm hearing
woven into this narrative that you're
saying
uh if that's how it's going to be i'm
not in nursing
kind of yeah that's kind of my
overarching yeah they're not they're not
going you're not going to acquiesce is
what you're saying
yes okay then you've got to choose a
different career and until you know that
i wouldn't spend a bunch of money on
further classes
i'd complete the ones you're in and
you can restart the classes next
semester can't you if this blows over
yes yeah i could technically and it does
work with the online system that i could
start them
sort of
any time but the one issue is because
i'm signed up in the courses already
it's a program
that times out
in i think it's seven years okay and i
think if you want to if you let me ask
you this because i i don't know how this
works in your particular situation but
most colleges most universities have a
drop ad system that there's so many days
into the course you can drop it and get
a full refund right
okay could you sign up for it and how
many days down into march
or into april can you still drop
that course and get your money back yeah
check with your advisor on that
and you i mean this what's what's the
term here i don't know what this is in
canada is it three years for the for the
program you have two years left i'm
sorry you have two years left
yeah okay
and you've got a seven year clock you're
not gonna hit that clock you're gonna be
fine
i think you're fine there um
i i heard another issue which is this
you and your husband have been gung-ho
gazelle intense and you created this
plan this idea that we're gonna have
this thing paid off in day x
and that is let's let's take the the
mandates off the table for a second and
you want to get get it paid off here
and
you want to complete your nursing degree
well it's actually going to cause them
to be able to pay it off because when
she completes that or pay will go up
it'll go up that's right so it's it's
six and a half dozen another i think you
have a long-term place so take the
mandates out if it's just staying in
school i'd rather see you go to school
and finish this program your pay will go
way up over especially over the long
term if you stay in nursing it will
that's right that's right you don't lose
your license and i'd rather you pay your
house off maybe a year later than your
plan that you all made up over dinner
one night then to yeah then to pause and
put yourself three or four years behind
making some major bank if you stay in
nursing of course yeah so yeah what i
would do is see if your drop add date
that's what i call it from the old
school your ability to drop the class
and get a full refund on this next
semester
if it is far enough out that you will
have news about your license
before then
um i think you know that you're in an
unfriendly environment
for
the near term even if they don't take
your license
agreed yeah
agreed and so you may make a decision on
nursing in general based on that too
and i'm not telling you to do that i'm
just saying that you know you've got the
long-term okay i'm out of the business
because they're going to take my license
or they're going to mandate this from
now on and i'm not willing to do it so i
just i got to have another career boom
i'm out
peace out i'm not doing this right i'm
you're not gonna violate my medical
freedom with totalitarianism i'm gonna
vote with my feet i'm out peace out um
if that's the case you're already out
right yeah um
if uh
if
you think that that this
will subside this this political
pressure
will subside and you can get back to
being a nurse without being vaccinated
and protect your medical freedoms um
sometime in the future
then you would stay on this track and
that's that's the judgment i can't make
because i don't know what the flip's
going on anywhere much less in canada
right so let me let me point this out
dave and i've had this call on my show
several times
once you decide i'm out
i will not let somebody tell me what to
do with my body i'm out
let that be the day you stop stewing
about it and be use that energy to go to
something else yeah right you've made
your call you've made your decision then
talking about it every day being angry
about it for the next six months it's
just choosing to live shorter it's like
true that's true if you quit any job
that's exactly right anything any
marriage
i don't like what's going on in this
company
i quit and as soon as you walk out the
door then keep going dust your sandals
off
just keep going just keep going you
don't get any more space it doesn't do
any good for you right to constantly be
looking in your mirror and go well back
because i got fired when i was 23
and i don't know why i got fired
i probably deserved it but the guy just
said pack your effing stuff in this fn
box and get the f out of my office now
and i went yes sir you should have
showered you know yeah that was it and
you know i have no idea what i did but i
probably deserved it i mean i was a 23
little fart you know i'm still being mad
about it now
i
dust my sandals off next thing that's
right you know i'm not
apparently he had a problem you know
it's like goodness gracious right you
should you got to bathe dave you got to
bathe got a bath i got a shower gotta
brush those teeth gotta brush that tooth
brush the teeth brush that two that too
what's this hour of the ramsay show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
show